continúa la información en las 24 pero
ahora hablamos de economía con nuestra
periodista experta en ir hablando con
daniela bienvenida pues vamos a empezar
hablando del paro de camineros en chile
que finalizó durante la jornada de hoy
sin liliana buenas noches el gobierno
chileno y el gremio de camioneros
anunciaron hoy un acuerdo que puso fin a
la polémica huelga que iniciaron hace
siete días esto para exigir seguridad en
las carreteras y lo cual provocó
disturbios y desabastecimiento en varias
partes del país en la última semana los
más preocupados fueron los exportadores
de salmón y de frutas entre otros
productos que no podían ser
transportados este gremio buscaba que el
gobierno acelerará en el congreso una
docena de proyectos sobre de seguridad
dado el aumento de los ataques que se ha
venido dando en los últimos meses y que
son atribuidos a grupos mapuches la
confederación nacional del transporte de
carga dijo que el gobierno se
comprometió a reforzar la protección en
la provincia de araucanía que ha sido la
más afectada pero advirtió que si no se
cumplen las promesas volverá
a las carreteras daniela méxico descartó
la posibilidad de aumentar impuestos en
su presupuesto para 2021 así es el
ministerio de finanzas debe presentar al
congreso su proyecto de presupuesto del
próximo año el martes según el gobierno
este será bastante austero para poder
enfrentar la peor crisis desde la gran
depresión de la década de 1930 lo que se
sabe hasta el momento de esta propuesta
es que no plantea un aumento de
impuestos y que se centrará en gastos de
salud programas sociales y proyectos
prioritarios de infraestructura el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
justamente había destacado el martes en
su segunda rendición de cuentas que la
austeridad era su fuerte por otro lado
en ciudad de méxico se presentó hoy un
plan de reactivación con inversiones por
más de 5 mil millones de dólares entre
recursos públicos y privados esto busca
generar unos 300 mil empleos en los
próximos años
daniela en brasil quieren abrir la
operación de gas natural a los privados
sí pues el congreso brasileño avanzó en
la aprobación de un nuevo marco legal
para el gas natural el objetivo es abrir
un sector fuertemente monopolizado por
el estado a través de petrobras y que
según las proyecciones podría generar
inversiones de más de 100 mil millones
de dólares y crear 4 millones de empleos
en 10 años pues el proyecto es conocido
como la nueva ley del gas que ahora pasa
al senado antes de ir a sanción del
presidente ya ir bolsonaro lo que hace
es acabar con las ya tradicionales
subastas que siempre terminaba ganando
petrobras y entregar contratos directos
a las empresas privadas finalmente más
allá del tema empresaria liliana el
objetivo es reducir a la mitad el precio
de este combustible para las personas
daniela y megan verter y el príncipe
harry incursionar en los negocios
cuéntenos de qué se trata pues mire el
duque y la duquesa de esas ex tienen un
nuevo hogar y este es la plataforma
netflix pues está muy famosa pareja como
sabemos decidió desvincularse hace seis
meses de la familia real británica
de su independencia financiera pues
ahora lo que decidió es probar suerte en
los negocios como muchas personas lo
están haciendo en este momento también
crearon su propia productora y firmaron
un contrato de varios años con la
plataforma de streaming netflix para
producir series sobre la naturaleza y
documentales y además también
programación infantil
recordemos que megan mar coll es actriz
pero aclaró que no volver a actuar
aunque ha hecho algunos trabajos con su
voz desde que abandonó a europa con su
esposo para radicarse en américa el que
sí aparece en pantalla
liliana es el príncipe específicamente
en el documental rising phoenix que se
estrenó la semana pasada en netflix
bueno pues ahora les vaya bien vamos con
los indicadores de la jornada
bueno en wall street ya se volvió a
costumbre por estos días batir en
récords
hoy lo hicieron de nuevo el índice
standard poor's y el nasdaq que además
tuvieron buenas ganancias la mayoría de
las plazas bursátiles de europa cerró
con aumentos de más del 1 por ciento
como por ejemplo londres y parís con
talladas por supuesto de estos máximos
un wall street y en américa latina las
bolsas tuvieron signos rojo
pero ninguna comparada con la mala
jornada de la bolsa de comercio de
buenos aires la ciudad del día le va a
gustar liliana son los 37 millones de
toneladas de chocolate que produjeron
los países de la unión europea en 2019
alemania italia y francia representan el
64 por ciento de ese total así que
quería estos países nunca sería
suficiente de daniela gracias por la
información económica y usted gracias
continúen con más cifras 24 punto com